it turns out that Vanguard is pulling
out of ESG did you guys see it's what's
a third of the global capital is that
really yeah pull this up dude there's
like a two week old article 50 trillion
dollars they're not playing this game
they're going economic well you pull it
up there's one like I wanna like you had
mention someone didn't mentioned talking
about like why kids are depressed like
human beings this is Vanguard CEO this
is holes out of the Net Zero managers
initiative and affirms his fiduciary
duty to clients we should this is day
one
it's like a week and a half ago yeah
seriously this is them being like hey uh
get what go broke we lost too much money
and uh now we have no choice esg's done
this is this is it this is it the blood
has been sucked out of the body it's not
done I mean it's it's it's this is good
but the ESG is is pushed by
ideologically motivated people so that's
like saying that a religion is done okay
it's not done but this is an example
that this of capitalism not functioning
with Communism communism is not
profitable and the capital system won't
use it